TIMOTHY JORDAN: Joining me now
to talk more about Nest Hub Max
is Prabhu.
Welcome.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Thanks for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So let's
start with a quick overview.
Tell us about the larger
screen, the camera,
and all of the cool
features that they activate.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
So Nest Hub Max
is our premium smart
display designed
for the center of
your home, and it
builds on all of the
great experiences
we built with the
Google Nest Hub, which
we launched last year.
So we've got a
10-inch inch HD screen
for an even bigger screen
for your Google photos
and for watching YouTube TV and
all of the other experiences
there.
It's got premium
stereo sound built in.
And it's also got a
really helpful camera
with all kinds of features and
experiences that it can offer--
everything from video
calling with Google Duo
to peace of mind through the
built-in Nest Cam functionality
that allows you to
keep an eye on what's
happening at home
to personalization
through a feature that
we're calling Face Match.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hmm.
Very cool.
And what's your
favorite feature?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN: So
I personally love the video
calling with Duo, because I've
got a two-and-a-half-year-old
at home, and he loves to call
his grandparents on our Nest
Hub Max at home.
And the auto-framing
feature of our Duo calling
allows him to run
around the room,
and my parents can still
keep track of what's
happening in his busy life.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's awesome.
Let's talk for a
moment about privacy.
And there's a huge
consumer demand
for privacy and
transparency about
our personal information-- how
it's stored and how it's used.
And this seems like
one of those things
that the team was particularly
passionate about and proud of.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Absolutely.
You're absolutely right.
We thought about privacy
from the very beginning
of our process designing
the Nest Hub Max,
and actually, even going
further back, the Nest Hub.
One of the reasons that we
had our first smart display be
one without a
camera is because we
wanted to make it
available as a device
that you would feel
comfortable putting
in any room of your house.
At the same time, we knew
that the camera unlocks
a lot of helpful
functionality, and we
wanted to provide that
option as well for consumers.
And so the way we
thought about designing
the camera was very much with
privacy at the forefront.
We thought about easy
and simple controls
for all of the features,
which are all opt-in features,
and you choose what
you want to use.
And there's simple controls,
like the hardware switch
on the back of the device that
lets you quickly just turn off
the camera and the microphones.
On top of that,
taking a step back
from the individual
products, we as Google Nest
have also tried to define a
set of privacy commitments
for the home, which articulates
our point of view on what it
means for us to respect your
privacy in all of the products
that we build.
And those are really
specific, factual commitments
about what you can expect
with your personal data
when you're using our
products in your home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: One of the
really insightful things
about the keynote
that resonated with me
was that there's a fundamental
difference between a smart home
and a helpful home.
Can you define that difference?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN: Sure.
So smart home
technology is fantastic.
It helps us solve
all kinds of really
interesting and important
problems in our homes
and in our lives.
But one of the challenges
with smart home technology
is it's kind of complicated.
It's not that easy to use.
And so we wanted
to think about how
we can solve that
as we push forward
with our vision for
the helpful home.
And there's a few key
tenets for what we think
the helpful home looks like.
One is that the
products in it should
be easy to use for
everyone in the home.
The second is it
should feel personal.
As you use these
devices, they should
get to know you and be able to
provide an experience that's
tailored to you and your family.
The third is they should
work really well together.
These devices aren't just
operating in a vacuum
individually.
They're helping fill
out your entire home,
and so your whole home should
work together really well.
And then the last is,
of course, the one
we just mentioned--
that it should really
respect your privacy
and that privacy should
be part of the design
of all of the products
that you bring into your home.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's talk
about design a bit more.
I think designing
for a screen that's
meant to be viewed
up close, far away,
and from different angles-- it
seems like a really difficult
problem.
Can you talk about
your design process
while addressing that challenge?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Absolutely.
So when we started
working on the Google Nest
Hub, the first smart
display that we built,
we were thinking about
that first and foremost.
Because we wanted this device
to feel like an ambient,
glancing device, not
one that needs your
focused attention for
long periods of time.
And so we designed the
user experience on a device
to be readable from a
variety of distances.
Obviously, the fact
that it's voice
means that it can be used
from both near and far.
Then when we went
to the Nest Hub Max
and we added a
camera to the device,
the other thing that
we thought about
was how can the camera help
solve that same problem for you
and your family in the home?
And so an important
decision we made
was to provide a really wide
field of view for the camera.
It's got a 127-degree
field of view.
So if you think about
all of the experiences
that you're using
the camera for,
from video calling, where
it allows you to move around
the room with auto-framing,
to the built-in Nest Cam
functionality, where you can
get a pretty good view of what's
happening in the room, to
the personalization with Face
Match, where our
thinking was, the device
should be able to tell
that you're looking at it,
when you can see it,
and when you would
be able to receive the
personalized experience
that it's giving you.
And so all of those
design decisions
helped us to feel
like we're extending
that, whether near or far,
it's a great experience
from the Nest Hub
to the Nest Hub Max.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
OK, one last thing.
During user research, what
was the most fun thing
that you saw someone do
that you didn't expect?
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
So one of the things
I love about our
user research is
that we get to see how our
products fit into their homes,
and we sort of get to feel
the impact that we're having
on real homes and real people.
And one small
example of an insight
that we get from that
research is, hey,
where do people put
our devices when
we get them in their homes?
And we learn a lot from, for
example, the other Googlers who
test our products and
help give us feedback
before we ship
them to the public.
And there was one
email thread where
a Googler who was
testing a Nest Hub Max
showed a photo of his living
room, where he had the Nest Hub
Max, which is already
a pretty big screen,
sitting right next to his big
flat-screen TV on the wall.
And that was
obviously not what I
had expected, because I figured
these devices are big enough
that you're going to put this
bigger screen in a room that
doesn't really have
another screen.
But we had a dialogue
with the Googler,
and we realized the value
of checking your assumptions
and learning from
what people do to fit
your products into their home.
So he loved the photo
frame in his living room
and loved that you could see
it from a little farther away
because it was bigger.
He loved the fact that
it had a clock that he
could look at at any time.
He loved that he could control
his TV in his home theater
system by voice
through this device.
And so I think that every
time we actually see
how our products fit into
people's homes, we learn a lot,
and that's one of the most
fun examples of research
that we do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for swinging by, Prabhu.
This has been really insightful.
PRABHU BALASUBRAMANIAN:
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.